[Music]
in this movie there's a great crying
scene over the top crying scene you guys
had to do and you know it was great it
was a guys take on crying which I
thought was really nice because it comes
from your observations a little bit
about how guys cry mm-hmm well I feel
like like in movies a lot of times
people would be crying it's just like
one tear that'll strain but I don't cry
like the Lord of the Rings - yeah just
like one droplet yeah of sadness mm-hmm
not me and my face explodes yeah yeah
I'm just like everything that's inside
from here just as soon out of my face
and I'm just like we're like emotional
ugly crier yeah well real we realize
that on the same day yeah because we
were supposed to have a very intimate
crying yeah it was just like it was
supposed to be like a real moment yeah
and where the director Jacobson is a
real moment where you guys get it teared
up that you kind of ruin your sister's
wedding
spoiler alert and and let's keep this
one real and then we both just started
like channeling your real crying yeah
and what's interesting is there's this
myth that women like to see a guy cry
because it makes them more vulnerable
they do not know when women see a guy do
that they're like oh I cannot breed with
him yeah I cannot have that Auto
offspring with that thing
it's quivering in the corner dude I
don't like you guys don't there's no
like off there's no like middle ground
there's no like just like kind of
weeping a little bit and then they're
good to go
women can leave they're better Reapers
yeah not bad yeah not me I just like
I've just everything is is out if you're
crying you're right you got a little low
with the using
keep the using up here above the net
don't know no what do you know it's not
losing technically I actually I think
for like guys crying is actually cool
like it's just it's letting out you know
emotions that you need to let out
everybody cries all right you know all
right now what you've what you put me on
the spot well yeah right yeah right you
cried out all some time
like you look after tech you look like
Popeye didn't work you are getting there
I should get there I'm gonna break up
with yeah we're good Popeye yeah
you